what are you doing Helen we're here to
be a I can't say that as you guys may
have seen in our videos we got some new
shirt designs in the corridor a store
this one that's actually designed by
Gabe and it's based off of our glitch
video twinsies if you guys like the
shirt or you think someone else would
like it as a gift you should check out
our store corner - digital comm slash
store each shirt you buy directly
supports these videos and helps us make
more for you guys if you don't do this
the stakes are pretty severe we have to
shut down the business and stop making
videos so it's pretty severe please
please we want to keep making videos
guys got jealous and ran never having to
use his legs so I need training wheels
and I developed a system I call it the
razor's edge
so I'm gonna go play the where is Mahara
Danny's thing yeah
the yzma hawk video yeah it's sharp as
always
I hope I'm a good actor oh hey what's up
Mari
hey what's up this chicken just kept
sneaking friendly I think we just had a
moment what are you doing over here to
be a I can't say that not supposed to
reveal we're doing don't touch my feet
back hey how could we talk about what
we're doing without revealing what we're
doing oh pretty colors you know so thick
my eyebrows are dude I know they gave us
a oh yeah that gave a good expressly
[Music]
we are up against a hard wall with
starting to shoot lifeline well we have
to figure out right now is how are we
gonna shoot five videos between now and
six weeks from now the fall is our
busiest most productive time but if we
don't get ourselves scheduled correctly
now didn't you lose all that means less
views less subscribers less relevance
next week we're shooting with fallout 4
video on Wednesday Ren and I are after
that is when we have time to shoot this
wizard battle video to also fit in nerf
overwatch I'm a fan of it I think we
should do it I must say I'm going to
need two days maybe three to shoot that
alright so we'll put within that week
let's do it you probably know that I'm a
big fan of cheese and I've actually been
starting to make my own us here this is
going to now start reacting with the
milk
I'll put salt on the outside and then
put it in the fridge and that's it
that's the extent of work I guess we'll
have another cheese party in a couple
weeks
cheese update and Jesus hardly coming
along uh problem oh she's no good yeah
it's no good he's got wrong number this
one too wet no one's going to looks like
it may contain cheese fridge so I can
control the humidity and temperature
this guy's okay but still really wet
there's water in here well let's see
what's inside
Oh little creamy you know I might have a
smile on my face I'm legitimately
disappointed I just laugh at life
strategies that's all here we go
yeah so flat something worth a look at
brown coloring it's gross
it's like corridor cheese isn't gonna be
a new channel anytime soon it's noise hi
hey Carmichael your girlfriend's here oh
no your breathe oh I thought you know
it's gonna get better with time I was
looking forward to that time the month
where we shout out all our best patreon
patrons but they're supporting us in
Iceland Ahuizotl Andrew Ryan Kelvin
Kingdom John Wells brine Veneto Adam J
Chile so so is Hiro the one and the only
James Bailey patreon is incredibly
important to us and if you guys are
interested in becoming one of our shout
outs just check out our page and we're
happy to add you to the list
[Music]